[Music]
jumping to conclusions tis why you jump
into conclusions if I comb over here
over here it's like a play on words hey
a guy who the internet thinks cheated on
his wife joins the comment section to
prove his innocence
so so though the wife that suppose I got
cheated on made a video now I'm assuming
no the guy that was accused of cheating
went into the comment section so this
Myra I'm reddit okay oh my credit yeah
of knowledge and also smut yeah I love
the simplicity it makes me feel like I'm
back in nineteen ninety-four social
media I was a moderator on an Eminem
message board the candy wrapper but it
was like that it was like it was another
way to talk about like [ __ ] kids or
something that's how I did learn how to
masturbate from the minim chatroom like
good internet predator came in there one
day and taught me eminem the rapper
Jesus yeah so anyway no wonder you're so
[ __ ] weird man I'm I had no friends
to talk to so I had to learn everything
from from a resources I could get your a
lot past life is so fascinating it's
like this hyper sexualized Eminem chat
room that had a rap oh yeah I do drop
bars sometimes yeah who came for the
first time while an Internet predator
told her how to do it that is insane
yeah you know I thought you had a thing
yourself and I didn't like fingers
because it hurt so then I found out
there was another way to do it that I
had no idea about
and Google was really bad at like
telling you how to do that like it was
really Booga was not good back then yeah
it was all about yeah are you looking
you got to meet her later in her life
she was the fight of losers you know
we've never hung out with her oh but but
you know what the first guy ever gave a
[ __ ] to I had researched how to give
the perfect blow job before like years
before I ever gave a blow job just to be
ready just to be ready for it and he
says best blow job he's ever done no I'm
just saying like comparatively he
probably had one in the half blow jobs
just bites your dick off
move on you heard her dick sucking try
bro [ __ ] out of you let you said that I
give anyway only a 14-year old guy would
like it things you were offended by
today I always get in trouble on JK man
never gonna happen
got it oh my god sorry you could [ __ ]
deny everything except this like I
wouldn't brag fixing 4-year research
takes my jeans when I was eight years
old
yeah oh I just be there as a parent
right like I come into my daughter's
room and she's over here what the
[ __ ] banana in her mouth like it's a
nightmare dude it's over well anyways so
about this guy yeah so he was an arrest
Red Sox game and this clip went viral on
reddit where people were claiming that
he was caught with the side chick yeah
they're really quick so the internet
took this and ran with it saying oh he's
cheating on his wife that's a site
capable of us what if that's his niece
or something trying to get into the
kisses I guess held on yeah so some of
the comments said right now this guy is
creating so many reddit accounts in
order to down vote this Jim yeah right
it looks like she's saying enough when
the gifs starts with us the twist is
she's telling him to stop and then
someone responded to that one saying
she's the cheater and he's the side
chick with the laughing emoji and then
another one says could have been way
more smooth about it by bending down at
a girl she's like that was gonna fool
anybody
then he'd hide his face and not offend
his side fish so then that was like the
reddit just went crazy with this and
then that's why they don't even have
proof they just made up their own story
they always do
mr. created a reddit account inside dude
what do you think David ok this was me I
was kind of all over the place during
the game a couple highs and and of
course love probably just juiced on the
game with a Cleveland has some good fans
they give me that they give me the
business and I welcome it that's pretty
big yeah it's really big alright but I
that's what I'm saying like wait hold on
he just lifted his arm up for all we
know he was playing hooky on his job and
he's [ __ ] chillin there and then he
sees himself on things that go [ __ ] so
apparently he also commented further
saying that he had no idea that they had
no idea that they were on TV and that he
can't remember what was happening there
specifically although they had a 10 out
of 10 date night guess my arm needed to
go through that's what he wrote so then
he ended up posting proof of his
identity because people didn't believe
that that was really him so he posted
this a photo of him and his wife well
that's his wife and it says his reddit
name and wife and then the date
and then what
she in the video yeah Wow so that's what
he was saying like he was there with his
wife so he was joking about the
Cleveland fans giving him business I
don't get that part I thought it was
like he was joking about [ __ ] the
fans or something no no he's a he's a
Sox fan so Cleveland fans were giving
him the business because he's in
sportsman's well um how did he even know
he was on reddit did someone to tell ya
I mean I think I even liked it on
Twitter I saw it I was like oh that
looks like a tune him over yeah it's
like it just went crazy didn't even know
he was on and he was like like that so
it just caught in the moment yeah yeah
and then people still didn't believe him
so then apparently his brother went on
reddit and posted further probably will
not believe it right well they don't
want to yeah that guy looks like someone
from a reality TV show
he's like a bachelor finalist show was
it it was something to do with one of
the Real Housewives had a spinoff lost
no no or Jesse from prank vs. prank oh
yeah yeah for sure
he looks like also just like like
literally 3 million American that's
about yeah making the band freakin
Internet man we love jumping to
conclusions
I love making stories up yeah it's more
fun it's way more fun I don't like the
real story
[ __ ] you see there's a lot of people in
our comments that make up a lot of stuff
like one I recently saw was that Joe
hates David because every time David
talks Joe is like looking off into the
distance don't you really think that Joe
he's David do you not realize that
they're like best friends all the clues
he show his clips only and there's
somebody's talk at this [ __ ] where
it's like it's like Nicki totally
jerking Steve off under the table at
1:41 and I'm like and I'm like what the
[ __ ]
like why would we why don't she jerked
me off here like but we're married I he
jerked off anytime what would I get
jerked off here at the office right now
in this moment
I like when they a relationship anyone
who's sitting next to each other really
grosses and creeps me out cuz they'll be
like Oh TIFF is cheating on KC with Jo
because look at them they have this
chemistry or they would be like Oh
Tiffany and David they got something
going on I'm like it's not they're like
my brothers grow economies like that
even possible every contract from every
constantly any time I do a collab with a
guy youtuber they're like they [ __ ]
they're like their baby
you know he's hitting that baby internet
so good morning it's like a guy in a
girl's making a video that's so funny
that they have such low standards for
you game up man kept some like
appreciate there's a little bit it's
like in the beginning I was playing like
I would play hot girl like a [ __ ] girl
purse missing this girl and sketches you
know yeah that type of girl that like
flirty girl or whatever but I'm a serial
monogamist I've only been in two
relationships in the past ten years like
that's so not me but like every guy that
did a video with it was like she banging
him
no she's [ __ ] dude well the way we
got together too because we were both on
YouTube people thought that we were
cheating from a previous relationship to
her that people thought like that we
were totally cheating they just make up
[ __ ] anything idea there was none of
that at all we not get together until
like two weeks after we broke up and
then there's people commenting like come
on tell us I bet you baby bear is
already born right like that's why
you're not on social media anymore honey
I've never cheating so baby
[Laughter]
oh sorry I was like confused for second
I like it when we switch up seats just
for fun
to change the energy and they
automatically think like Barton G or
fighting or like you and Casey aren't
getting along right now the last video
the last vlog that you had with Noah in
it people were like Jessica's totally
[ __ ] Noah I [ __ ] got on there and
I was like throwing up as I was deleting
all those comments because I was like I
can't let this exist in the universe
like it's so disgusting you know people
don't really know it
Noah so unfuckable was throwing up laws
delete lines karate kicks in his teeth
get weaker [ __ ] are you watching JK news
right now takes off his genius it's down
a source crap you like 10 years younger
than me is a little baby it's just weird
huh they come up they they do come up
with some interesting things though
sometimes I'm like oh my god this is
like a saga that you guys created your
head it's like a soap opera
no no don't say like my friends are
Isaac's real dad when it's like I don't
even know them when I was born which
makes it even crazier that he's there
that it's [ __ ] no I get that you're
gay and I'm your beard I guess I love
though I'm away with you for your money
[Laughter]
you know that's the one comment that
cracks me the [ __ ] going for the money
thing no it's just like the fact that
people think buddy I wish it was Turk
you have a Tesla day well you have a
element David a Honda Element now I
understand it makes sense now you know
he spends money like a guy who doesn't
have money for long
he's got broke money like I got I have a
Tesla right there like you guys test it
look at what I'm wearing like that's
like the one nice thing I got in five
years
like please dude we did show up here in
a charcoal suit then he took it all oh
that's right I did forget about this
entire rings I didn't like is it the
jewelry that gets you is it the fact
that I keep my credit cards in my phone
tell me what did the shoes tell me it
what is there up there what what is it
that makes me seem so baller expensive
hair country huh my god dude if I was
balling good I will shove it in your
face so what they pursue you by the
first thing you fight the first thing I
would buy is a slap here you go
here's 5,000 bucks fix your face later
ugly hope Oh move on to the next can you
slap me first write in my tip boom that
was super rich I would move into the
palace oversee damn the super-rich I
would only take shits in the Palace of
Versailles so you have to go to France
just to take a dump all that so yeah I
have some local [ __ ] spots super rich
all we get a brand new Honda Element
with zero miles on does it even exist it
hasn't been a production in like ten
years but other than that we would have
a [ __ ] house a bathroom house just a
hangs own house you know saying a kiddy
house I hope you guys enjoyed this video
for more please subscribe to our Channel
and you can check out the last video
right here
[Music]